deswegen dazu bei
seinen stunden wieder
land die lage kommen in dubai der flug
war wie eine achterbahnfahrt allein
hierbei der gepäckabgabe es alles schon
so krank luxuriös alter ich fühle mich
direkt teuer weil man noch dubai weise
will braucht man bei jane reisepass der
mindestens noch sechs monate gültig ist
einmal durch den westen reisepass noch
sechs monate und acht tage gültig ist
wichtig jurist und dreimal dürft ihr
raten dessen koffer gerade nicht kommt
dann sind wir halt im hotel angekommen
erst mal hieß luca tag bei dem schneiden
sind wir auf jeden fall im hotel
angekommen wurden dort begrüßt mit so
pansy grings und so was man hat uns ein
mensch mit seinem golf cart ähnlichen
gefährt abgeholt und hat uns einmal klar
dass kanzler hotel dings gefahren und da
geht es jetzt weiter
durch wohl zu verantworten und jetzt
sind wir sofort in unserem zimmer ein
tolles gebäude ihr wird der raum
das kleine ist ja mal richtig fit zu
werden
hier vorne hinter haben wir die dusche
hier bin ich daraufhin zieht der mit
seinem ganzen leben die vornamen sollen
badewanne da kann man baden gehen aber
man kann auch von der badewanne ganzen
gekonnt hierhin geben
hier schlafen wir verliert also dahin
sind wir angekommen hier ist das bad
hier können wir und dann ist der ball
kommen und man schaut dann halt so und
jetzt hast du überall pool wo man
schwimmen kann aber ich kann nicht
schwimmen und ich sind hart müde weil ja
meine letzte nach zwei stunden
geschlafen
ich werde so oft halte und ich will
eigentlich dfb-pokal gucken weil bayern
gegen berlin spielt aber das einzige was
sich empfang ist so ein seehund
fernsehen er ist kein fußball mehr
gucken und panel gang und jetzt kommt's
erneuert hat es ist ein neuer tag waren
schon frühstücken passt das hell gibt
euch einfach dieses wunderschöne wetter
in deutschland sind so am arsch auf
jeden fall gehen wert am strand das
julius fuß gesetzt schön haben strand
yahoo.de gewissens die sonne ball hat
auf jeden fall übertrieben
zeitungsbericht eingecremt und schützt
sich immer gegen einen sonnenbrand
die trasse soll bald legen jetzt der
kessen in so einem coolen australisches
restaurant sind gerade auf dem weg zu
diesem australischen restaurant wo ludo
dich jetzt essen gehen werden und ich
wollte dem hotelier schon ein paar mal
erkannt weil ihr wollt auch einige
deutsche sind und ein junge mit dem
hatte ich schon ein foto gemacht der
kamerad nochmal meinte helga können
vielleicht lernt machte zürichs teilte
haare und alles schöne kritiken sind auf
jeden fall in das restaurant eingang und
haben dort geredet an der aktion update
saison hatte kein tisch heute werden
jetzt verhungern
ja wir sind um jude hat dann auf jeden
fall noch beim roomservice angerufen
das heißt da werden doch nicht voran bis
morgen
jetzt am strand ein stressiges leben
hier oder blitzgerät uns wäre ich bin
fertig mit duschen und service war da
und die haben es einfach so viel wasser
gegeben
also ich trinke jeden tag 20 auf jeden
fall gehen wir jetzt in dem restaurant
was essen wo wir gestern ja nicht
gekommen sind weil wir kein tisch hatten
also mal schauen wie es mir ja sie
komplett aus
es gab schon wieder ein neuer tag ich
weiß gar nicht mehr wann wie wo er weiß
ich auf jeden fall mal sagen muss dieses
befehl dieses frühstücks buffet das ist
echt das absolute chaos liegt
wahrscheinlich daran dass nur viele
leute von überall auf der welt
aufeinandertreffen aber da läuft einer
rum da stellt sich jahren dringend sich
der erfordernis einer die gabel wo die
die melonen mit dem partner sind die
frittierten nudeln ich mich um laufen
mich zehn indische kinder um das
traurige ist halt auch das heute
tatsächlich übel bewölktes wetter als
wir gehen aber dennoch an stand heute
die sind hart im nehmen
die leute helfen sich schon stressig es
folgten vor der sonne
ich halte ich nicht mehr aus
ruhig und ich glaube schon erstmal
aufkommen über 9 und da hast du aber es
gibt halt nur die leute und die leute
weil es auch den anderen her über sms
heute ist auf jeden fall der erste tag
wo jude und ich nicht nur den ganzen tag
am strand liegen und dort ganz viele bis
sie termine haben sondern wir fahren
jetzt wirklich mal in die stadt der über
verrat uns jetzt gerade in dieser dubai
mall rausgelassen und wir sind jetzt
direkt
[Musik]
das so broschüren
das ist wahnsinn dann kommt die außen
ist okay das sind kranke hochhäuser
wollten dass anstatt da
jonas 4000 meter mit rang elf
[Musik]
foto wenn man mal habe ich muss jetzt
zum essen gehen extra lan rausgesucht
der hier in dubai als kulturelles
meisterwerk gilt geil halt ja wir waren
jetzt gerade weil diese nicht spielen
von dem
das ist zumindest fraglich denn solche
grabmal
das ist schon krass was die hier alles
auf die beine gestellt haben ich
schließlich meine hände lampe bei mir im
zimmer zu installieren
am ein sonnenbrand ist es genau 24
stunden her dass wir bei diesen
lichtspiel mehr im burj khalifa waren
wir waren heute allerdings den ganzen
tag nur im pool und eingeschlafen und
deswegen den tod sonnenbrand im gesicht
und alles tut einfach weh wenn man
gerade essen bestellten büro das gerade
alles auch vor der abfahrt wir sind hier
auf der palme und wir haben hier unten
was bestellt und um zu uns zu fahren
können der opa fand dann ist hier erst
lang und dann hier einmal komplett um
ich hätte das anders gebaut
[Musik]
das essen war nicht so heiß und wir sind
dann auch direkt an googles neuer tag im
paradies eine karte sehr gut im zwei
karten auch weil das sich seit der
ersten tag wurde ich dass mein fuß gehe
ich weiß nicht ob man das richtig
erkennt aber es regnet wir sind in der
wüste wie kann sie regeln auf jeden fall
tatsächlich wir hatten jetzt gedacht
dass wir heute eigentlich den wüsten
tomaten aber die wird hält glaube ich
nicht angeboten bei so einem scheiß wert
durch den sturm gestern nach das ja das
ganze gemüse um gefallen was ist hat
denn fürn scheiß wetter hier immer das
ist nass auf dem boden kann aber nicht
gebucht der hat bestimmt sprinkleranlage
angelassen guck mal hier leute
regentropfen es regnet alle zwei monate
in dubai und gerade dann wenn wir sind
die tante am beach stand habe ich das
richtig mir sagen man hat im winter
richtig verstanden habe auch gemerkt
dass mich die tante am die pflanze
besser ankommt habe weil das wetter
aufgeregt habe und sie aber irgendwie
außer dem hintergrund gefilmt habe und
ich darf sie dachte dass sich mädchen
hat sie irgendwie aufgeregt ich werde
sofort alter update das wetter hat sich
ein bisschen aufgeklappt und wir gehen
jetzt noch am strand wir sind dort
und gegangen weil es einfach so kraft
wendig ist sieht man dass stars sind auf
jeden fall geht die sonne ist schon so
halb unter und sieben menschen
das stativ ein paar sekunden später doch
nicht wirklich sehr gut deswegen haben
jetzt gerade auch schon warme dusche und
jetzt diese sachen bei morgen fahren wir
dann fliegen klingen die mit zurück nach
deutschland
und ja damit ist der block 1 jetzt auch
zu ende auf jeden fall das erste mal
vereinigte arabische emirate für jule
und mich und es hat uns sehr gut
gefallen wir waren eigentlich nun dubai
und dort auch primär die ganze zeit nur
im hotel aber das war ziemlich cool weil
wer soll entspannungsurlaub bisschen
sonne frischen luft und rauskommen aus
dem trotzigen schweiz deutschland oder
ich super geiler blogger den habe ich
mir gedacht ich film ein bisschen was
also soll ich gefallen hat würde ich
mich übernommen hof räumen und falls
nicht da muss ich wohl leider blockieren
[Musik]